eight-point lead for the thunder
here's thompson who just checked back in
him knocked out a three
now will this be the final 12 minutes of
the season
for the warriors who had a magical
[Music]
thompson a rainbow three
clay thompson with his eighth
three-pointer
the playoff record for threes made
look at this catch and release are you
kidding me
he's not even squared up yet he's
squared up as he's shooting
and that's the type of face that
everybody makes because that was just
the nasty sick jumper
iguodala had it knocked away recovered
by vulgar they get it to curry
and he fires over
keeping it alive thompson turning and
shooting
what a shock by clay thompson
he is brittany norm a tough difficult
three-point shot exhibition that's all
heart and
[Music]
[Applause]
there was no foul call and now wait a
second boulder pointing
back early third and he is now defending
curt thompson
off the drive klay thompson who has had
a terrific night 33 points
equally at the end of second half and
you see what that patience does it gives
him time to get set
and knock it down a long three-foot
option of that is an nba record
his tenth three-pointer of the night
it's an nba playoff record for klay
thompson
hold on curry his third and roberson
will head
don't let the pretty shot fool you
that's hard
to be able to be down and to trust your
skills
to let it fly here tonight and move on
to the nba finals for the first time in
2012.
westbrook stumbling lost it
again thompson fires for three
yes golden state by
three
as you couldn't be as patient as a team
coming to your building
a lot of quick shots by oklahoma city
a few vote attempts in the first half
now 10 for 31.
craig thompson adding to the lead
time-out taken by
oklahoma city this crowd has gone silent
a new playoff career high
for klay thompson 41 points he also
equals his overall
career high in terms of three-point
shots with 11 that's it
looking to throw in can't find anybody
like the red king from out of bounds and
they turn it over
and curry just runs it out
and that will do it in one of the
shockers in terms of the comfort behind
effort
that we have seen in the playoffs this
heads to a game seven golden state
coming back
from a 3-1 deficit to tie the series
at three